we begin with breaking news about
WikiLeaks founder Julian Assange Sweden
just dropped a long-standing rape
investigation against him for the past
five years he has claimed sanctuary in
an embassy in London to avoid
extradition Assange his lawyer calls
this a total victory but Assange
believes that he's still wanted by the
US for leaking classified information
Jonathan Vigliotti is outside the
Ecuadorian Embassy in London where
Assange is holed up Jonathan good
morning good morning Assange has lasted
five years living inside this embassy
his lawyers calling today's decision a
total victory saying he is set to walk
free but the truth isn't that cut and
dry the u.s. is considering their own
charges against Assange and here in the
UK he faces a lesser charge of failing
to appear before a court in 2012 if he
does step out the Metropolitan Police
say they will move in and arrest him
Julian Assange posted this smiling image
to social media moments after the
Swedish prosecutor announced they
dropped the allegations against him it
brings to an end a case that started in
2010 when Asajj was accused of sexual
assault but refused to go to Sweden to
allow himself to be questioned fearing
that he would be extradited to the u.s.
to face charges related to WikiLeaks
2010 publication of classified American
documents in September 2011 Assange
shared his mission with 60 minutes if
you're a whistleblower and you have
material that is important we will
accept it we will defend you and we will
publish it in 2012 to avoid extradition
to Sweden
Assange jumped bail and took refuge in
London's Ecuadorian Embassy where he has
remained ever since despite his apparent
seclusion Asajj still found voice on the
world stage in 2016
WikiLeaks published thousands of emails
from secretary Clinton's campaign
something that then candidate Donald
Trump applauded they want to distract us
from WikiLeaks
it's been amazing what's coming out on
WikiLeaks
but the administration of now President
Trump is seeking to clamp down on
organizations like WikiLeaks we will say
put some people in jail federal
prosecutors are assessing whether to
file charges related to the release of
stolen US information we are going to
step up effort and already are stepping
up our efforts on all leaks the 2010
document dump leaked tens of thousands
of classified files and sensitive
diplomatic cables and led to the arrest
and imprisonment of Chelsea Manning
Manning was released from prison
Wednesday and Swedish prosecutors just
held a press conference where they said
they could technically reopen this
investigation and the unlikely case that
Assange decides to go back to Sweden to
face questioning before the statute of
limitations expires in 2020 Alex
Jonathan Vigliotti in London thanks
Jonathan